das hier ist mein letzter Einsatz für
die heutehow das BSW sucht nämlich noch
einen Social Media Manager und wer kennt
sich aus mit tiktok insta und Schüler VZ
tja ich tschüss ihr Trottel ich habe
gesehen die Stelle für den Social Media
Manager ist noch frei ja wenn Sie wollen
haben Sie sich beworben ja das mache ich
jetzt hiermit das meine Bewerbung
Bewerbung läuft anders das wissen sie
bisschen was aufschreiben muss man schon
also so ganz ich ich hab meinen
Lebenslauf dabei ne also 2014 NRW
Abitur
also es ging kontinuierlich Berg ab und
den Weg möchte ich halt fortsetzen ich
habe mich auch für Social Media Team
beworben wirklich ja ja dann pas wir do
perfekt zusammen ich habe direkt schon
was vorbereitet so ein paar memes okay
sind i memes in Begriff memes noch nie
gehört lustige Bilder im
Internet SAR Post vor der
linksparteiustig schon gekauft es gib
natürlich für Parteien die erfolgreich
sein glüsbringer und natürlich das
genaue Gegenteil hallo Herr laontain
hallo was wollen sie von mir sie haben
ja schon mit SPD und der Linkspartei
kurzen Prozess gemacht können wir darauf
hoffen dass sie sich treu
bleiben also ich glaube in diesem Fall
können Sie nicht darauf hoffen
denn sie müssen auch immer eines sehen
das passt war nicht so richtig in die
heute show aber es geht immer darum dass
man politische Überzeugungen hat und die
sollten eigentlich darüber bestim in
welcher Partei man ist mus du selber
lachen gerade ne nein ich lache nur weil
es ihn schwer fällt das zu kapieren das
fällt mir wirklich schwer ich meine sie
sind in die Partei Ihrer Frau
eingetreten Söder ist ist ja bestimmt
Begriffen SAR ist SAR ist super in dem
Fall ist Sarah russisch Brot wegen
russisch ich habe schon verstanden ihre
Ambition habe ich schon verstanden ja
und natürlich wollen wir zeigen dass wir
zusammen stehen dass wir für viele
Themen stehen dass wir tolle undierte
Menschen unseren reinhaben Trolle tolle
russische
trlle nein hab ich war wahrscheinlich
eine freudche Fehlleistung ich habe
tolle gesagt dass wir für viele Themen
stehen dass wir tolle tiktok z.B ist ja
ein wichtiges Medium um die Partei nach
vorne zu bringen weiß ich nicht habe ich
ke einfach in die Kamera mal liebe
tiktoker ja liebe tipter wir gründen
heute neue Partei und ich hoffe ihr seid
viele von euch W uns
unterstützen einmal so drehen so genau
dann so und dann so nach oben okay und
dabei sagen wir müssen sie dann sagen ne
liebe tiktoker herzlich willkommen ja
liebe tiktoker herzlich willkommen beim
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht haben wir im
Kasten war das gut das war super das BSW
will ja ganz genau darauf achten dass es
keine realitätsfernen wköpfe schaffen
Mitglied zu werden ja früß ich warum
sind sie trotzdem hier na ja ein paar
wirköpfe muss man ja ja tragen können
dürfen rein
eigene Inhalte Inhalte klauen welche
Inhalte klauen wir denn ja also bei der
AFD wird ja viel z.B absolut nicht
absolut nicht nee ne ne ne ja was das
Wording angeht das ist ja schon recht
ähnlich ne das würde ich auch nicht
sagen ne im europaprogramm steht z.B
dass die EU vasal der USA ist ist das
gleiche wording wie bei der
AFD in kleinen also wissen sie das ist
meiner Meinung nach purer Populismus
wenn man kleine
Begrifflichkeiten bei so einem großen
Programm oder bei so vielen W dann so
kleine Begrifflichkeiten sich raussucht
dann gibt es wahrscheinlich dieselben
Begrifflichkeiten no bei der SPD bei der
CDU und anderen Parteien also ja also
wasasal der USA nicht mag sein ja warten
sie auf mich wir hatten unsere
Differenzen umso wichtiger sind doch
jetzt
Friedensverhandlungen ist ZDF heuteh
machen sie Späßchen da sind viele die
gerne Späßchen ma ich will natürlich die
wichtigste Person sprechen soum
Moment jetzt mit mir friedensverhandlung
ja gerne gerne ja gerne klar konnt es
denn seit kommen dass ausgerechnet sie
den Bündnisfall
ausrufen es gibt immer wieder Neues in
der Politik das ist jetzt wirklich eine
witzige Frage unbed witzige Frage ich
bin geadelt von Oscar lafontain das
heißt ich beende jetzt meine Karriere
und ziehe mich in den Ruhestand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist der zwar nicht wahrzunehmen
aber ich würde eure Hunde kurz
rausbringen okay
fertig